der tu graz beim arzt und ja ich bin
jetzt sterben wahrscheinlich ja aber am
knie oder was ja wir müssen der kerl hat
man sagen die tour serie und das ein
bisschen tinnitus ist wissen wir ja gibt
es trotzdem kann man trotzdem singen
also zu für die zuschauer zur erklärung
tinnitus das ist dieses greifen wenn man
wenn eine airline denkt da hat man das
kurz mal aber wenn man es dauerhaft tat
ist blöd es wäre blöd aber ich denke
dass wir schon wieder weggehen ok in der
kälte ganz abgeklungen ist
kannst du denn mit tinnitus könntest du
singen oder ginge das nicht doch doch
ich habe schon sehen
es ist nicht so laut als das hat mir
medizin natürlich dass auch nicht nur
werden auch wenn ich alles wo ich es
natürlich die sie
ja ich hab den ton ist nicht okay
das ist ein a das könnten b sein
mbr praktisch das ist gut für den song
wenn das der richtige ton ist dann kann
ich daher denn einfach augen auf den ton
genau super user setzen wir setzen uns
darüber stehen
und unser youtuber müssen ja sagen unser
staffel so ist es echt so oder ist nicht
wieso ich finde diese spitznamen den
youtube ging wie finde ich ein bisschen
youtube hat youtube kennen sie mich also
okay aber erstmal bin ich ja auf youtube
nicht der king da gibt es ja einige wie
zum beispiel die ich die reisen nicht
größer sind aber ich kann nicht so gut
sind wie du ja aber ich weiß auch nicht
mehr auf den spitznamen com is you tube
kinks und es gibt auch den klick
millionär
aber gut ich kann da nichts für also ich
hab mir die spitzen habe ich ausgesucht
das waren redakteure am schreibtisch
genau aber gut und es hat mir geholfen
auf youtube ist jetzt einiges dazu
gekommen in letzter zeit ich bin jetzt
bei 101 tausend abonnenten glaub ich war
vorher auf 86.000
und zwölf millionen aufrufe hatte ich
vorher und jetzt habe ich glaube ich 19
schon fast
also wenn man mal bei youtube ein
bisschen größer werden möchte einfach
mal ab zum fernsehen es hilft ich sage
immer so lange es das fernsehen noch
gibt soll man es nutzen als youtuber
eigentlich schon oder ja ich bin
demnächst auch in einer ard serie ab und
zu zu sehen aber das verrate ich noch
nicht die serie ist der neue tagesschau
-sprecher quasi
bisschen anders aber zeitlich ungefähr
in der ecke fast echt auf einer dvd
aber es ist nichts großes aber es ist
lustig ich bin gespannt das ist man da
kommt ja immer auf immer mehr youtuber
kommt sowas zu erstens weil aus youtube
sicher wirkliche profis
herauskristallisieren sei es gesanglich
sei es comedy mäßig sei es sei sein und
zum zweiten die medien schauen immer
mehr ich habe jetzt iks presseanfragen
die alle eine doku machen wollen den
radiobeitrag in online beitrag also
arrivierte medien die kommen jetzt immer
mehr drauf bei youtube ist auch richtig
was los ja kann ich nur zustimmen dann
ist der hammer das witzige ist ja dass
man kurz erzählen ich wusste ja
eigentlich oder ich hätte es ahnen
können schon monate bevor er weiß wenn
wir es auf kreta story auftaucht ich
erinnere mich dass war waren das ist
glaube ich war im sommer haben wir uns
getroffen in berlin im nh oder auf der
terrasse des nh-hotels oder hast du
gerade trainieren abgedreht und da hast
du schon so gefallen hat was machst du
denn hier ich habe mich auch gewundert
du hast mal gesagt du fährst mich und
ich habe gesagt nee was mich habe ich
echt ok ich meine man trifft sich
irgendwo auf der welt und ja wir waren
kurz vorher zwei tage vorher in köln
glaube ich beim videodreh stimmt was ja
auch sensationell war hammer war richtig
gut fantastische auftritt und ich
erinnere mich auch noch an deinen
auftritt beim deutschen web video preis
wo die leute wirklich so saßen wenn du
das sagst das war so das ist auch wieder
dieses jahres gehört wahrscheinlich am
18 august jetzt im januar entscheidet
sich ein bisschen später ich hoffe du
kannst du kommen ich hoffe ist ja ich
weiß jetzt natürlich nicht wie das hier
alles weitergeht mit beweis und was
danach passiert aber wenn nicht der zeit
hat dann komme ich auf jeden fall vorbei
du musst kommen ich würde du musst
kommen wir auf jeden fall ich wer du
bist ja dann wenn ich das richtig sehe
ist das im juni in brüssel
veranstaltungen du kriegst am schluss
wenn du gewinnst oder überhaupt die
klinge alle universe vertreten
alle alle und zu denen habe ich einen
guten guten draht recht ja kannst du
kleines wort für mich ein lediglich im
vorfeld finde ich sowieso da kann ich ja
nur gewinnen ist super der christopher
ward gesprochen na ja so ein bisschen
darüber genau da hat es angefangen und
so dass auf jetzt bist du hier für dich
dein aussage von youtube über obwohl ja
schon natürlich ich nehme mir aber
dieses youtube gingen auch schon noch
mit dem ganzen die ich meine glaubt die
betriebe sind noch fleißig im boden für
mich da habe ich schon genau das müssen
wir unbedingt sagen also wer dieses
video her sieht voten voten voten
anrufen bis der draht glüht oder die
luft vibriert bei drahtlosen telefonen
also anrufen anrufen anrufen unbedingt
es ist wahnsinnig wichtig unheimlich
wichtig ja das würde mir sehr viel
bedeuten
ich möchte noch ganz gern bisschen
weiter mitmachen hier
aber und das ist glaube ich der punkt
bei diesen ganzen anderen sagen du hast
die leute mit einer stimme weg gewählt
hier jetzt überhaupt also auch beim
webvideo preis beim beim video day und
das ist und ist das auch hier so oder
wie kommst du ja an also das ist ja das
erste mal dass du ich meine diese
resonanz kriegst was sagen die leute
oder wie reagieren die was ich meine
narri narro
sie hat geweint als sie nicht gehört hat
ja beim betteln ja ja ja das war schon
war schon herzzerreißende auftritt das
war den habe ich auch sehr schön da hab
ich ja falling slowly gesungen zusammen
mit den masters erinnerst du dich ich
erinnere mich bei ihnen auch echtes
guckst du auch ich leiste dann fleißig
was ich gucken was ich gucken kann
glücklich und das war ein absolutes
highlight auch einen song dem eigentlich
so nicht kennt bestimmt um den habt ihr
gesungen deshalb ein recht umbauen
vielen dank christoph und du hast diese
battle gewonnen ich habe es gewonnen zum
glück ja und dann war ja darauf tritt
jetzt bei der live-show habe ich jack
reed gesungen kannst du kennst du in
euro in st nein echt nicht nein sogar
ich kannte den ich bin da gerade mal
geboren als darauf rief von radiohead
echt nicht oder kenne ich den krieg wenn
ich den sing mal bitte
ja ich kenne nicht sorry ich hab
radiohead auch damals nicht gehört echt
nicht unheimlich ja aber das war auf
jeden fall ganz cool innendienst habe
ich auch gern gesungenen song und jetzt
am freitag gibt es
nächsten knall us und das sagst du
natürlich nicht sagen natürlich nicht
verraten
okay das heißt du bist guter dinge dass
du weiter kommst ja so guter dinge kann
ich dann nicht sein ich meine konkurrenz
ist echt krass gerade mit personal zum
beispiel der hat den medien den
absoluten hype gerade das heißt der ist
doch schon mal außen vor der kommt so
oder so weiter tippe ich mal und dann
wird es zwischen den anderen dreien echt
knapp könnte knapp werden aber ich
glaube das wird cool am freitag ist dann
wahrscheinlich mit e gitarre auf der
bühne und dann wird dann müssten
abgerockt sensationell was ist das jetzt
mein gefühl ist ein ziemlich krasses
gefühl das was hier gerade abgeht ich
meine wir wir kennen es ja jetzt schon
ein bisschen länger da war ich noch so
der kleine youtuber und jetzt somit den
ganzen kameras die hier immer um uns
herum sind die ganze zeit machen wir was
wir frühstücksfernsehen und für taff und
dann im studio zu stehen auf so einer
großen bühne mit den ganzen kameras mit
dem publikum und mit dem wissen dass da
gerade irgendwie 4 millionen leute
zuschauen das ist unbeschreiblich
echt wahnsinn aber
gut nächste weiter warm ich würde schon
gerne ein bisschen weitermachen
danke dir